[Applause]
my god you look fantastic thank you
all right good
how are you thanks for being here thank
you for having me yeah you know i i
don't i don't want to i don't want to
bust you here for anything but an intern
on our show
came uh we have interns
an intern on our show uh came into the
office uh like a couple of weeks ago and
said i just saw mila kunis serving
drinks at a bar she's a bartender
downtown yeah and all of us were like
nah that's not true and this and our
intern swears it's true is it true yeah
well yes yes yeah yeah mm-hmm so you're
part you're bartending on the side yeah
i finally get paid for it i just do it
because it's fun and then my friends and
i drink for free so it's a good way to
get plastered right
i never thought of that before they'll
so now wino's everywhere i'll be like
i'm a bartender too
uh so so that's how you how did this all
come about in the first place a friend
of mine works at this bar down in the
lower east side and
just one day i went behind the bar and
started making drinks and i'm kind of
good at it so i just did it what kind of
drinks do you do you make um are you
good at any one drink well i just well
yeah well i kind of make a peanut butter
and jelly shot that's really good and
not very many people know it but i just
learned it right right so would you
think a guy was what would you think of
if a guy came in and asked for an
appletini the guy asked me i would send
him to my friend to make it because that
i don't know but you wouldn't think less
of the guy if the guy wanted an
appletini yeah well i think he'd be you
know a little but now i wouldn't think
less of her
do you like appletini oh i don't know i
i don't
give me a whiskey or
i love an appletini uh such a refreshing
now what do people think when they come
into a bar and don't they people must
recognize you but they don't believe it
they're like oh she's much prettier but
can you get me a drink and i'm like oh
okay right like some people did they
don't you know they can't grasp it but
some people believe it i'm like yeah i'm
like no you're not and then we get into
an argument over it they yell at you and
yeah and then i'm like what do you want
me to say yes or no and they're like
well just say the truth i'm like yes no
like they just don't right so it's a
weird thing all around yeah and what if
that's just gonna become a celebrity
trend like you know i i know somebody
else does bartender in new york that's
um a celebrity and another bar i think
people just do it because i mean like
other jobs like you know you go to a
mattress store and ashton kutcher's
there and he's like you know
try this it's firmer you know you might
as well try it with country sure yeah
yeah why not now uh i understand you
went to disneyland recently yeah i
haven't been in i think i went like in
spring break in college yeah i went to
disneyland after i had an appletini and
you see the kind of guy i am first the
appletini then disneyland
uh well how was it was it fun it was so
much it's fun because
um we didn't have to stand in any lines
it was my friends and i ended up going
and my friend will works for disney now
and he got us all these tickets um do
you get self-conscious at all like
cutting it i do it first and then i
don't because
at least you're honest yeah i'm like oh
i feel bad yeah let's go on it again
right like you just kind of go with the
flow of it's great oh my gosh it's great
right right um and then actually a
friend of mine who was with us we got
the privilege we had little kids with us
we had two five-year-olds and it was
their birthday and so they're like do
you guys want to meet the characters and
we're like sure so they brought us into
this private room in the back of
disneyland with like mickey minnie goofy
pluto and like mary poppins right right
and you know you hug these little
plastic characters and whatnot and then
my friend's like trying to hit on minnie
and i'm dead is serious about this like
you know little plastic mouse right and
uh and he's like hey let's go out
afterwards oh wait i don't want to break
you and mickey up and she just points to
her hand and she's like
cause there's no ring there right and
then making minnie start sparring and
these little kids got a little freaked
out like it was it was funny for the
adults but the little kids did not get
it wait so minnie was sort of saying
like i'm available in front of mickey
and i love that mickey's kind of jealous
and he's got his own issues yeah yeah if
he's not gonna write commit that's
what's gonna happen yeah and goofy's
probably like i've seen this before
those two need help
that sounds like a lot of fun all right
i got to go back
um
now this weekend i understand you're
doing this is cool you you're the voice
you're a voice on the family guy very
popular show and you guys are doing a uh
a stage reading which means that you'll
see all the actors is that right it's
you know what it's really fun if you're
a fan of the show and if you love the
show i completely recommend you going if
you don't like the show don't go because
you're not gonna have fun right it's
serious it's for i mean you know it's
one of those things where you get to see
the actors on stage just read um a
script right but it's great because seth
macfarlane does you know 400 voices and
it's just really fun to see such
talented people on stage well you know i
used to think i when i used to work in
the simpsons years ago and i would think
uh and every now and then i'd hear the
the the actors yeah that the actors were
going out to do a reading somewhere and
i would kind of think well who really
wants to see that as compared to an
episode when you actually see it and
we've had a bunch of the actors here
from the simpsons doing the voices dan
castle now people like that they do the
voices and people go crazy because
they're seeing the voices come out of a
person believable people in the audience
we did it in la and we did it in
montreal and they were crazy right they
were the first like the the first like
sentence stewie had to say like you
could not get into words and edwards for
like you know good 20 minutes people
just went crazy right well people should
check it out uh uh that 70's show airs
wednesday nights at eight on fox and the
family guy premieres this sunday night
at nine on fox mila that was really fun
thanks for doing it thank you yeah we'll
see you next time mila kunis we'll be
right back the raven app stick around